eine private angelegenheit ist der
letzte film der brüder taviani die seit
gut 50 jahren das geschehen im
europäischen kino mitbestimmt haben
[Musik]
kommt viel geld verschlang hatte wurde
das anders als alle früheren filme der
taviani es allein von paolo gedreht
nachdem sein bruder vittorio bereits
durch einen autounfall andrehen
gehindert worden war und dann später
nach dem fertigstellen des films im
april 2018 gestorben ist
paulo taviani wird vermutlich nicht mehr
alleine filme drehen so dass man
wirklich in diesem fall vom abschluss
eines lebenswerks sprechen kann
es geht um einen jungen partisanen am
milter sogenannten nach seiner vorliebe
für englische literatur der gegen die
faschistischen truppen der sogenannten
sozial republik italien unter mussolini
der nähe von turin im piemont kämpft
dieser mülltonne hat vor dem krieg ein
mädchen kennengelernt fulvia hinterher
sich verliebt hat er hat allerdings
einen rivalen namens george der offenbar
in seiner abwesenheit mit full wir eine
affäre begonnen hat kern ist aber diesen
giorgio sucht er jetzt unter den anderen
partisanen bei einer anderen einheit zu
der er sich erst durchschlagen muss bis
er dann erfährt dass giorgio bereits
gefangen genommen wurde von den
faschisten und vor der erschießung steht
jetzt versucht mülltonnen der unbedingt
von giorgio wissen will was mit fulvia
passiert ist einen faschisten gefangen
zu nehmen um ihn austauschen zu können
gegen seinen freund gegen seinen
konkurrenten um mit diesem sprechen zu
können
aber das geht schief
dieser film wie viele filme von den
brüdern taviani erzählt von einem tiefen
grundlegenden menschlichen konflikt dem
konflikt zwischen privaten gefühlen
privaten sehnsüchten und dem gang der
geschichte dem was man die große politik
nennen könnte auch hier geht es also
wieder um eine tragödie die einerseits
ganz trivial und ganz privat und und
persönlich ist und die große geschichte
das große geschehen als hintergrund
[Musik]
das ist den pavés wieder einmal gelungen
ist diese beiden ebenen miteinander zu
verflechten das zählt zu den großen
vorzügen dieses films andererseits fehlt
hier der große überblick den man oft in
den filmen der taviani sieht es fehlen
die großen totalen und vogelperspektive
es ist ein fast privates
kammerspielartige drama das sich
letztlich immer um diese suche des
partisanen billiton dreht nach seinem
freund aber auch hier spielt die natur
eine nicht nur beiläufige nicht nur der
chor hafte rolle auch hier ist sie
sozusagen der spiegel der inneren
verfasstheit des helden und so ist er
auf und abstieg durch die berge des
piemont in denen sich die handlungen zu
trägt immer auch ein weg durch die seele
dieses gequälten studenten durch seine
eifersucht seine reue seine sehnsucht
nach dem zustand wie er vorher war seine
hoffnung auf das kriegsende und am ende
hat unser held immerhin eines gelernt
nämlich dass er sich nicht von der
vergangenheit abhängig machen kann dass
er sich befreien muss von seinen
gespenstern wenn er ein eigenständiges
leben führen will
so endet dieser film mit einer großen
perspektive auf die landschaft die den
krieg schon hinter sich hat